[Music]
what's been the best part about training
with Mike
[Music]
Tyson is he the best boxer out he going
ready fight the greatest fighter in the
last F and maybe the greatest fighter in
the world ever at first he wasn't even
like oh I made my Ty in one day from
where I was it wasn't even a possibility
wasn't even an
option when he wins yes he'll be the
best fighter yeah Crawford well listen
the results speak for itself I don't
have to say anything I don't have to say
anything you know sometime you you think
it's not real sometime you you think
you're dreaming or you're tripping I
here Jack with this guy
and that that's basically what I want
you for fury because Fury is bigger than
me it's real right it's real you're dead
with my T and talking Fury is bigger
than me and that's what I want to you
know yeah push feel p p you got push on
your leg get get quick got
F he was very kind even talk about like
technique boxing techniques to some
stuff when I watch you think I the
uppercut you right uppercut I always
knew that he was a brige for me to
create my way and get get somewhere in
boxing the level what do you think you
bring
Francis always illusion this fight is a
dream boom boom I think I bring him the
confidence because when somebody get
here the first reaction this is a
reality not
dream
but he has developed elusive qualities
and has the most important quality the
will to
win cut in the left hand Thomas trying
to hold on serious trouble and down he
goes now let's take a look at the knock
you know we talk about
[Music]
finish
and at the top of the
heat Francis and ganu hoping to
eventually hit that rarified
[Music]
air
so almost three years ago uh on the
podcast in LA and uh in that same
podcast um we were uh asked came if you
will be in my corner or give me some
tips help me training whenever I fight
Tyson Fury because that was already in
uh that was already my goal back then
and he said yes and today is just the
accomplishment I never thought much of
this um training stuff but I see I can
um I could push him and I could um push
him to the
limits oh get a match up with a gun
that's going to be interesting fight I'm
like I'm going
to long I'm going to welcome you here
and I'm going to meet uh give you the uh
return you the service in the ring yes I
mean I [__] won that tyon fur fight
we had Tyson here too we had here too is
this your next fight I'm the boxing
heavyweight champion UFC heavyweight
champion and we're going to find out who
is the B on the planet really powerful
fast Tyson Fury's in a tougher fight
than he
[Music]
believes guy like Francis for a fight
like this he has to constantly throw
punches Tyson can move good well so
constant attack you can't go out there
Toe to Toe slugging you got to cut them
off chase them mhm cut the ring off yeah
I think he's got good
[Music]
footwork and he had good speed too he's
got great speed he's he's got great
power yeah listen this is but you got to
move your head against Fury you have to
but I certainly feel the cuss
combinations to three four and five
punch combos that we teach him are going
to be devastating from
Fury when they throw just one or
two Fury handles that that's no problem
for him he easily Ducks he moves he's
he's unbelievable I agree experience
he's a great boxer for a 6'9 guy to be
such a great boxer it it's I know but
we're going to have this 67 guy chop him
down exactly absolutely and you cut down
a ton of trees Francis has tremendous
will and it's the will of a champion
he's got the will to win and along this
journey he's going to become a boxing
professional World Champ Champion mark
my
word let's do this go
[Music]
ahead want to grab it you got it yeah I
got it I got it
ah look at
this hey guys the training technique
Fran need is a lot of boxing a lot of
sparring all the the physical straining
running lifting weights that's beautiful
but you need to practice on what you
have to do and you have to box so you
should do as much boxing as possible
leading up to the fight what are you
doing
Chad I asked I ask him if he could be in
my corner whenever I fight Tyson Fury
and he say yes you get
it
Billy damn that's
cool Billy I think we should get this
guy
working around the ring let see end end
mean endurance age endurance exactly see
it is
[Music]
down what do you want to get out of this
this whole
experience the victory first of all but
also to
um have to fulfill the experience and to
prove the world that I can do it you
[Music]
know
when you're hitting the bag right I see
you hitting when you walk I want you to
do like this bo bo b boom it keep for
boom bo boom boom how long you can do
that one two one two one two combinate
boom like
punch the bag is going to be in trouble
you can miss you were doing Bo boom boom
you can miss
I'm a pro I never miss it's straight one
two straight
one get closer to the bag jab get
closer CL yeah when jab you boom punch
through the
B make it more subtle make it not like
Bo boom Mak
like you feel
this I've been do that when you
think the further you pull your back
your hand back the harder you punch but
it's not punching comes with relaxation
real real good pinpoint accuracy
punching you can hear the guy P boom hit
the guy at the right
target oh
yes
yes yeah that's what they going need to
beat the
champion you have to understand when
you're first learning and he's got a
he's got a style all his own um Mike
comes in or if anybody comes in and
teach you something new it's tough to
pick up listen listen when you do that
right and you punch like that never back
up like if you punch boom boom boom then
move last whatever punch is the last one
you move on that side all right don't
never stay after you finish never back
up go
forward so never don't retreat when you
punch it move here never never move here
always where the punches can go this
way oh that looks good keep your keep
your
balance knees bent power come from your
knees move around the bag boom boom boom
get around it okay yeah keep your hands
up 30 get 30 seconds just punch for 30
seconds boom boom boom boom boom boom 30
seconds come on come on keep don't
stop keep going keep going keep
going chin down chin
down eyes up chin
down
keep gone keep gone hey oh that's
beautiful beautiful beautiful that's
what we talking about that's what you
going to need to get the title
baby the way of train punches which was
very interesting because that also like
uh get me get more impact without push
putting more power you know so which is
exactly like the reason why uh I love
his ti so
[Laughter]
[Music]
much take on the first give t to the
chest first before you release that bomb
t to the chest that's
one so you feeling
it yes
sir one
more he has to be aggressive with his
jab like he's been doing in the gym
coming forward
punching to the body with his hard
punches and bringing it to the head
throw the first two all fast all
combination
quick oh
[Music]
yeah that's
one so you feeling it break the
RM yes
sir you know what else when you throwing
the right hand right when you throw the
right hand try to push you up W so can
go through him I want him to throw the
punches through the guy not at have to
hit the guy just boom now with the full
force so I was showing them how to throw
the full force without bringing your
hand way back and throwing the punch I
showed him short distant
punching you know you want to go through
[Music]
him oh
yeah you have to have brains to be the
heavyweight champion you just can't win
because you big and strong
strong there's levels to this stuff
man the strongest guy doesn't always win
this is a smart man sport only the
smartest
one oh throw it when you get there you
throw it as fast as you can hard as fast
cuz he can't see you huh
yeah
sh yes you know when you throw that
right hand you know even though it hurts
the way you punch it you're punching it
like this that hurts but you got
to pushing really everything in it it
hurts too when you just go like that but
you got to put it all in stopping with
one punch
yeah try just start off with a jab start
it with a jab do I want you to do this
take it that like
ja you got to be fast boom boom jab boom
boom
boom yeah he's been in the ring before
he knows the in and out about fighting
and it's just that we had to transer
that because he's using his legs and
elbows and everything grabbing so we
kind of I don't know did a new found um
foundation and made him more of elusive
you know made him more elusive he thr
his punches with just bad intentions and
um I used to believe the um the
consistency of the hard punches to the
body to the Head what he's capable of
doing we need your legs like this can
you go like
this can you go like this instead of
going like you got to go like
this vender just go down B all the way
as far as you
can go up let's go like this go through
this 20
times yeah yeah that's perfect fr can
mix his footwork he again is a
tremendous athlete mixing his footwork
with his punching power it all works
hand in hand it it flows like water as
Bruce Lee says and let me tell you Tyson
Fury said uh it doesn't matter if he has
Muhammad Ali Bruce Lee and Mike Tyson
training him the fact of the matter
is all of those three combined um are a
novelty of the cus style um of a boxing
Style that uh Mike knows uh like the
back of his hand and uh he knows in his
sleep and the moves he's teaching
Francis get in front of him you get in
front of all right do that again go
down I want you do this when you go down
like this see see me let
me can bend look life o o
oof
bend your La make sure you bend low as
you can O then do this you
conf here I'm always intrigued that how
people talk about my and power my and
power and nobody talk about his
technique and now I'm like this do what
generate his power his foot work is
insane his base is insane his transition
everything goes from like every pches
was backed by his entire body weight of
course he could have go through a wall
through a entire brick wall like
that by just putting transfer all his
weight on his punch because he has a
good base and he was able to shift and
this and move like that like not
heavyweight have ever done that before
like trust the foot walk hold your hands
like this I then you
go
just oh yeah relax your arms relax don't
punch hard your thumb don't don't try
hard just let the punches
[Music]
go beautiful beautiful beautiful bend
your leg some more get underneath it
diger frontes up just like that that is
perfect J put your chin down look at
your eyes yeah perfect just like that
just like that try to come forward a
little
yeah oh that's so beautiful that's
better than all the hard punching in the
world go ahead just want to see how far
how much he wants and how far can he go
how far he wants to go before he says
no
let punches go let them go don't
keep move those hands move those hands
right you know fighting wasn't something
that I decid that I'm going to fight or
that I decide that I going to love it I
just love it this is what it's about
Bend those leg keep that head chin down
Tuck your chin yeah
I always love fighting you know and
uh I was just burning with it
and there's nothing specific that were
like okay this what get me to fight
right I always love everything that was
about
[Music]
fighting close your mouth
go like this now come up come up Put
Your Hands Up come up boom boom boom
boom that
now one two keep it going boom boom boom
boom one
two oh
beautiful Mo a little
faster let's try to go through don't
have to be hard just try to push through
the pad you don't have to be faster just
push through it you some power little
power to go through it
go through the pth just go through them
that's all
fin then your leg keep your legs bent
stand down and have go keep
[Music]
p
it's beautiful it's
beautiful that's what it's about this is
what boxing is
about I have to get into that Mike Tyson
body the Mike Tyson mentality his his
stuff with his food workor and
everything boom I'm powerful just just
jab and
B oh perfect jab just go through that
pad make sure that jab goes through the
guy like a battery R yeah oh that's
beautiful do it
again whoa
who do right hand left hook too that was
beautiful R up R it you rip it with
everything you got keep your necks bent
just rip it with everything you got
don't care if you're tight everything
try one more
[Music]
time always comeing throw it right here
come close jab Come
[Music]
Close yeah the move whatever hand you
hit you go you move to that
[Music]
side left up
B you got to think of throwing punches
your job is to throw punches don't hold
you have to in the way be conscious but
black out being
conscious it's really interesting mind
game fighting it makes the fighter your
mind makes the fighter so much better
than he actually is this the last round
all
right sa things make it more yeah
[Music]
I want to just jab and you throw the
body punch as hard as you can they jab
boom boom
boom look this doesn't happen overnight
as kaso said but the fact of the matter
is it does happen and it can become
second nature um Francis is on a journey
to become the UFC he already is the UFC
heavyweight champ he's going to be the
first guy to be UFC heavyweight champ
and world champion boxer at the same
time it's it's unheard of it's never
been done before and it's comparable to
cus uh teaching the two youngest
heavyweight champions of all time Floyd
and Mike I want to you jab and you throw
the body punch as hard as you can they
jab boom boom
boom oh yeah jab Body by come keep doing
it jab Body by it's over and over jab do
it
again put the jab through him good
straight yeah do it again so when that
yeah yeah yeah throw right through try
to go through the pads with the right
hand throw it fast
too yeah he's going to punch you
back that all
low Hey listen he's good for right now
maybe he wants to do some exercises
something and put it in good work for
your first day Francis is a fast learner
he's a quick learner and and again Mike
is as intense a trainer as he is a
fighter so you know this is just the
beginning you hear me Francis this is
just a beginning you didn't get started
yet and that's very important when you
pick up what you're you're learning it
becomes in your mind you put it in the
mind and now he's practicing that it
becomes second nature over time and
that's where it's going to be very
beneficial to his elusiveness his head
movement his allaround athleticism and
again he's UFC heavyweight champ soon to
be boxing heavyweight
[Music]
champ he did a great job though well I
could see that he didn't believe that
this was going to be as hard as it was
and I and I wasn't too hard that
particular day I justed wanted him to
break a sweat before I could could see
what I was working
with and since then it's just been
consistent hard
work that's what it's all about it's
about wanting this it's about wanting to
hurt that man to change your whole life
if I beat him my whole life change not
forget if I get a big payday my life
changes if I win I said well that's how
he should think and in order to be the
heavyweight champ of the world the
heavyweight champ of the world is very
objective he has no feelings he don't
care if his mother in the ring his
brother in the ring anybody in this ring
they have to feel the fury that's just
what it is I don't care if my mother my
brother don't get in here don't get in
this ring let there's no um sympathy
there you know there's nobody going to
show you any compassion in there you
know that's just what I was told kill
him before he kills
[Music]
you since the beginning of
boxing since David since ailles since
all these guys man this is what they
want everybody wants to be a fighter um
the heavyweight champ of the world could
be any man walking on this planet in a
fair
fight I wanted to be a part of that
[Music]
world
[Applause]
[Music]
on the back I mean on the P how many
rounds are that combined that is 12 12
huh that's 12 n he has to go more okay
let's do that and then I was going to
think I was thinking six on the pads and
then an additional maybe two rounds of
just stuff on the bag if you want do
that yeah we can do that what's the
first I want to do the bags shadow box
for two bag for two bag for two with
catches and counters six rounds of pads
um and then two more extra rounds or
whatever you want do n um that's not
what he's going to do he's going to hit
the bag for more rounds than that he's
going to do 12 in here alone
okay it's a lonely sport buddy even even
in the room of a lot of people this is a
lonely
[Music]
game Fury usually has a major advantage
not just
height-wise not just weightwise and
wayon is opponents and wears them down
but he has a tremendous reach Advantage
however for this fight intriguingly it's
only a 1-in reach advantage that Fury
has very compelling very
[Music]
interesting that's where Mike comes in
he had a often times a major
disadvantage reach wise against on the
tail of the tape with his opponents but
matter of factly he out jabbed the
majority of his opponents uh I don't
remember one ever out jabbing him let's
put him on the
bag I need you um work on your jab this
round throw
it
jab
yeah
do it three
times when you punch the punch when you
jab right ask as if you taking out um
you stepping off a cigarette see watch
my foot see that when I push it it
turn keep going a
time yeah youb more come on push through
it powerful man push through that boy
like a battering ramp yeah push forward
come through it boom push it bring your
body
forward yeah you want to hurt him with
that jab I want want two Jabs like this
boom boom boom see how the right hand
going right through boom boom boom you
push everything you got go straight
through the bag all right bend your legs
when you punt yes see that power come on
you got it boom go through the bag just
come on with that right hand boom yeah I
need you when you
[Music]
jabing
st moving your feet
try yeah you try you can jab ja two
times two
Jabs jump move keep it moving off your
feet do right hand after one of those
ja boom boom boom Oh I put it through
oh
beautiful keep that come on another yeah
come on keep that left hand up when you
finish punch it soon as you finish
jabbing put it
here put the jab up jab jab pop come on
let me get let me get some of this let
me get some of this let me get
some pop around go around the bag jab
around the bag yeah yeah move around
come on move around every time you punch
move around move around punch move
around move move move get out of the way
move move go around the
bag yeah but hop around hands up left
hand
up come on move around move move
around move around but stay close the
way he could um make it more effective
is to put a lot of pressure on him
that's what he's going to have to do
Tyson's very um elusive has agility to
be such a big man and so that's why I
was contemplating that Francis would
have to put a lot of pressure on him
punching body
punches
beautiful do it all put the power in
there the leverage dig your feet in the
floor dig your toe in the floor move
around yeah oh move
around yeah good
footwork oh try it again after that left
hook rip rip that right hand right
through that bag
right
oh yeah do that again now hop around
brother hop hop jump in the air jump
jump jump don't don't move your feet I
need yeah I need to do
that jab ja ja hey hey yeah that's what
you need move move move standing to
stationary move move hop around the back
hop hop keeping that left hand back when
that right hand
up come on dig through there man doing
some hard work this what you have do to
be the champ of the world move those
hands move those hands yeah come on
let's do it
baby oh come on that's good that's good
try it again look go right now got to do
another one brother hop
around oh hop around beautiful leverage
try not to not try not to pull it back
too far right try to
do okay come
on come on you keep your right hand up
good bring your left hand back when you
finish punching hop around be a rabbit
hop around hop around do the punch yeah
just like that come on come on move pom
pom again oh perfect that's what I want
that's what I want that's what I want
that's what I want hook hook hook hook
another one come on right now right
quick right now again again another one
another
one make sure you're breathing that's
beautiful when you breathing that's how
hard you punch so much harder breathe
relax breathe come on 30 seconds I need
this I need this come on I need
this come on just like that don't go
like this
go go ahead come
on harder come on man put that punch in
there come on man you got too much power
to punch like that come
on come on come on come on come on come
on come on come
on
oh
keep
woo ready to wrap up ready to get it
things so all right hey we going to do
some ring work the first time I worked
out with them it was a good workout then
I asked them if I'm saw from the first
day I said no I was saying to myself
that's a bad mistake that he told me
that and I think you I'm like oh you
shouldn't say that and the second day he
he make sure that I was
so one thing CU show them thing like
when you jab you know you see how I
leave when I leave them he he throws his
whole body in it like sticking
everything out the whole thing he try to
do like
that stick it all all the way jab D oh
yes
oh
that's so much different huh right bu so
much different what they were doing come
on go through keep pushing like you're
pushing go right through push your leg
wait get in
there harder come on push your legs keep
your legs under you at all
times with that's what you didn't doing
on The Bag Man just like the speed is
great come on push yourself man you
got
push this over three three try three of
them go hard hard three hard come on
push them through like you had the other
on O Come on breathe too
man come on do snapping fast like you
did earlier breathe relax you're not
punching breathe breathing is so
important cus always said calm and relax
when you say calm and breathe and relax
you're not tense you're able to see all
as Bruce Lee said see all things when
you see you're able to breathe you're
able to relax you're able to stay
calm punch Hard Punch hard with that
JB
oo we're going to do that
come come on bend that jab
quick right back
that's what you need baby he told me it
wasn't sore
today you
do looks
good you always worry about being
humiliated and beaten and that's why you
train so hard and work so hard because
you don't want to endure that feeling
even though that feeling is a great
feeling to bounce back from
it's still that feeling you have to deal
with
it and some people who who make mistakes
or believe they failed in a particular
general just a particular instance they
beat themselves up it's good to beat
yourself up and don't have limits don't
go too far boom boom tell yeah make sure
he does what he does does that yeah you
ain't do that on the B I didn't think
you know how to do that [__] come
on
come come
onoo he's doing a good job brother doing
a good job no let's just try and do the
jab liver over
first oh put make sure that foot is
turned put that that toe in that ground
put that cigarette butt
out oh see the
difference oh put it it out put it out
dig it in the ground bend your legs man
come
on woo come on keep coming through move
after you
punch move move pop around man move move
it's all about the experience of being
in the ring fighting it's all about
getting comfortable with the ring that's
what experience is about knowing the
ring feeling comfortable in the
ring no you had do he want this what
what did you do upcut liver liver liver
over yeah he want he want this yes sir
you saw that look
here hey hey yeah
[__] I'm going do it
again oh put your whole body it's
everything dead rip put it in them oh
[__] don't pull your hand back too much
just dig it yeah oo they can't escape
that get over hey come on two seconds
come on last one
aho I like that I like
that come on walk around you got to walk
brother got to get some walking in man
this is what fighting is about
endurance I want him to be um alert but
relaxed you know I want to be very alert
ready for everything but be relaxed
breathe take it easy observe what's
going on you know become part of this
become one with the whole and volume in
at this particular
time Bo jab no I one like
this three Jabs watch one one two and
then jab up jab on it it could be up jab
but it could be like this too
boom boom boom boom straight head
boom
faster yeah
faster faster
FAS bend your leg after you now after
you do that bend your
legs Bend go down with your leg try
SL come on fast as you can doesn't even
have to be that hard
fast ooh
see
yeah the last one push your body into it
yeah like P let me
show
push it in the last one you saw that one
oh no watch one more
time say th in there let like o put your
whole body in the last one oh
yeah
yeah yeah do this one more time
right boom boom boom come on little one
more time who
e come
[Music]
on oh
yeah
yeah no put thr that straight the last
punch is a straight patch like a jab go
ahead you did the last round put your
hands up man yeah do it again last punch
the hardest the jab on me yeah no no
take your punch punch like this I want
you not to go like this I want you to go
like this boom you understand see that
it's it's more round it's not straight
it's
round you that
everything round
yeah make the last jab up do
them oh
yeah
yeah keep your hands
up now listen left hook last last punch
left hook after the right hand go ahead
do it
again one more punch just one
[Music]
time woo that's the next
round
[Music]
it's just um it's just very exciting
know you have the hardest puncher in the
world going up against the heavyweight
champion he's proved his knockout power
he knocked out some monsters in the
UFC and um he's improved so much as a
fighter and I believe that confidence
that he has and that burning desire that
he has to set um
I don't know he wants to set the stage
for um where he com for he wants to make
them
proud that's not good
enough let's take the gloves
[Music]
off
this might be the opportunity that I've
been looking for so it's time to shock
the
world get the raps off from
Billy please but my life is fighting I'm
a fighting man I believe in fighting and
um that's what he is he's a fighting man
cuz he's been fighting all his life
coming from Africa coming to France
coming here and I'm dealing with a bunch
of quag Myers and that's the champion
Spirit right there so it doesn't um it's
not far from the champion heart and
that's what a champion do he goes
through adversity and he overcomes
adversity even when the position when it
appears that he's lost he still fights
back and overcome
adversity he's very well equipped he
knows that um once he gives up all the
opportunities and all the doors of
opportunities Clos on him and that's why
he never gave up and that's why he's um
he has a chance of being a big big
winner there's no gu guante of success
do you have enough passion to keep going
no matter
what oh get back a little bit cuz it's
don't hard yeah
three four if you believe in it you do
it you believe in something you do it
and it's not only combat for everything
that you can do in life when you believe
in it just go for it and uh mostly don't
let people tell you what you should
5 6
[Music]
16 and I have seen that a lot even
before I started this oh they tell me
how old I was they tell me how this tell
me man here we are so don't listen to
people listen to yourself and it's okay
if you fail
because you is a part of life it's a
process right it's the you better fair
in your decision than sometime be right
on somebody decision because when that
person is not around then you screw but
if you fall with on your decision then
you learn from it and make it right for
yourself the next time last on 20 you up
and walk around
brother
[Music]
want to be heavyweight champ this what
heavyweight Champs
do it's almost over 40 more and it's a
rra 400 more no 40 40 more and it's a
rap he's having a difficult time right
now
[Music]
ah I believe he came here for a reason
all what he's endured to get here make
him a special person I don't really like
focus on the W um I think I focus more
about me like what I can
do how good am
I or how far I can go I think that's
enough because the war is is a is a is a
is very wild he a wild animal you can't
control you can only control one thing
and that thing is
you be your first
fan be your first uh
believer and the rest will come let's go
oh I like that willing
willingness let's go
baby give it to him now
yeah oh we still got a lot of strength
two
three four you make it harder like that
that's makeing it even
harder come on come on
Francis fight your demon fighting come
on you'll feel this way in the fight two
seven
more eight six
more five
more come on come on come on this way
this where you got get dig down deep
come on you're in the ninth round come
on man you got him hurt keep on one more
20 right there right sir all right one
way listen you did you did 80 already we
all go home after this 20
okay 20 away from the best part of the
workout I know rest and recover
rest a little difficult than yesterday
right you really hurt my feelings when
you said you wening sore
today oh really a shame shame right and
I always complain about how life been
hot for me and uh then all of the sudden
I realized one thing let's go ready
let's do this do with your legs like all
the way back like you do that
there's only one reason for why I keep
falling again is because I keep standing
[Music]
up come on man it's over come on the
last minute of last 30 SEC 5 Seconds of
the fight come
on come
[Music]
on
yeah last one last one come
do so if I didn't stand up the first
time I would have never fall again you
know then I'm like so instead of like
focusing on like how I've been falling
which is the negative of it part of it
maybe I can focus on like how much I've
been standing up right and now I'm like
damn this actually means something that
mean I'm
[Music]
tough that's only 10% how Fighters train
right there that's that's it's nothing I
didn't is nothing that's how Fighters
warm up and so he's going to have to um
get very familiar with that kind of
lifestyle of fighting being a fighter is
almost like being a
monk yeah I would equate a fighter a
true fighter that follows the rules of
fighting that's a
monk yeah he has monastic lifestyle it's
Fran's
time Fran's
time you have to believe this you have
to know this one thing I'm going tell
you and this is spiritual right see all
your fights and stuff all all your
Knockouts is spectacular
know what that means all this good stuff
happening to you know what that mean
that you're favored by God you know that
right yeah you know that right but this
something you this something that you
may not know too when you're favored by
God you're also favored by the Devil
he's coming for you too so you just got
to be strong and stay on the right side
who side you going to go on he's going
to give you power too he's going to get
in your head too but who side you going
to stay with you stay with who brought
you here go home with the guy that
brought you to the
dance
[Music]